العقيد الخاص بك كان هناك بعض
التحليلات من منظمة مراقبة روسيا أن بوتين
كان يماطل تاريخيًا
في أي نوع من الردود
التي رأيناها شهدت الكثير من التغيير في
القيادة العسكرية على مدار
هذه الحرب ، وأريد الحصول على المزيد
من الأفكار من  أنت على هذا الجنرال الجديد سيرجي
سوروكين الذي تم إحضاره وهو
معروف بأنه رجل وحشي وشخص كما
قال جيل للتو والذي تم إلقاء اللوم عليه في
تدبير الكثير من الأعمال الوحشية التي
رأيناها في سوريا يعطينا إحساسًا بما
تعرفه عنه.
الجنرال سيروفكين شخصية مثيرة للاهتمام للغاية وهو معروف
بوحشيته حتى ضد زملائه
الضباط آه لذلك أنت تعرف أن هذا الرجل أه
أنت تعرف شخصية مثيرة للاهتمام ليقول
أنه على الأقل يبلغ من العمر 55 عامًا أه
قاد سلاح الجو وهو نوع
مثير للاهتمام  بالنظر إلى
حقيقة أنه جنرال بالجيش بالفعل ولذا فأنا
متأكد من أن ذلك خلق الكثير من الاستياء
داخل سلاح الجو الروسي أه وذكر جيل
أنه هو العقل المدبر للحصار
من حلب هذا محق تمامًا أه
كان أحد المسؤولين فعلاً
عن ذلك وهو من الواضح أنه
حامي لنظام الأسد في
سوريا ويمكّن هذا النظام من البقاء في السلطة
بقدر ما يتعلق الأمر بتحركاته التالية
أحد الجنرالات الثمانية الذين شغلوا
مناصب جديدة في
الأشهر الأخيرة وهذا شيء
أه يظهر أن هناك نقصًا هائلاً
في القيادة أه والثقة في تلك
القيادة داخل التسلسل الهرمي الروسي
وأن انعدام الثقة أعتقد أنه
امتد إلى  أداء أنا
في هذه الحرب ، لذا فهو وضع خطير
جدًا لجميع المعنيين في الواقع